all right by uh popular demand i'm going
to do a sort of full review of the
andrew cuomo
covid cover-up claims that are
circulating so we can try to
sort of sort out what's truth and what's
lies and what we know about and what we
don't know about and sort of what's
relevant to policy versus what are sort
of like the more
a personal scandals in which andrew
cuomo is now
embroiled so let's get right into it
earlier in the pandemic
new york democratic governor andrew
cuomo was seen
as sort of a model governor in
responding to the pandemic
and despite new york being hit very hard
early believed to be because of the
number of non-stop flights both to china
sort of like source one for the virus
and italy and surrounding parts of
europe sort of like source two for the
virus
in the united states despite that the
idea was that cuomo
handled the virus as well as was
possible given what we knew
at the time and ramped up testing
relatively quickly
as quickly as feasible put in place
guidelines
did shutdowns as necessary and while
much of the united states
had three spikes new york was able to
completely suppress
the what was typically spike two for
much of the country in the middle of the
summer
and they had uh basically the initial
spike
and then the fall spike limiting
themselves to two spikes rather than
three
thanks to andrew cuomo's great work now
until
more recently some very serious
allegations
of the covering up of deaths have
surfaced so let's go through the
allegations
from the emails i've gotten a lot of
people don't actually understand what is
even being alleged
now i want to be up front that much of
much of this is still disputed and
contested
and just about every report has some
detail
that is not at least yet confirmed but
we're going to do the best we can to
parse through the evidence we have
the big scandal and the big allegation
is
that at andrew cuomo's either direction
or uh indifference nursing home
coveted deaths were under counted by the
state
allegedly to the tune of thousands of
nursing home coveted deaths and indeed
the new york health department has made
public
data that added more than 3 800
nursing home deaths to their tally after
this story broke and the state now
acknowledges
that they upped nursing home deaths by
about 40
now it's really important to be clear
here and this is what a lot of people
may be missing
this is not an allegation that new york
under counted coveted deaths
nationally even globally we believe that
there have been far more coveted deaths
than the official numbers
because of people who died including at
home and were never tested
but the allegation is not that the full
public number of new york coveted deaths
is being artificially suppressed any
more than just we're probably under
counting covert deaths at a global level
the current new york coveted death toll
is about 47
000 and that has nothing to do with
these allegations what's at
issue is how many nursing home residents
died
and our best understanding of the
undercount is that there were
thousands of nursing home residents who
became so sick
that they went to a hospital died in the
hospital
and they were not counted as nursing
home deaths
now in a literal sense they did die
at the hospital but we all understand
that if you are a nursing home resident
who catches the virus at a nursing home
you should be counted as a nursing home
death from the standpoint of evaluating
how well did andrew cuomo protect
nursing home
residents and that's the crux of this
even if the total number of deaths is
not being lied about
if you undercount nursing home deaths
you are making it seem as though
you are much better protecting nursing
homes than you really are
so this is dishonest and andrew cuomo
has to be held accountable
this has a real impact it's not just
academic
it's not just a number families
make decisions about facilities for
loved ones
in part based on whether they believe
their loved ones will or won't be safe
at nursing homes if you falsely believe
that there are way fewer nursing home
cover deaths than there really are
you might make a decision about a loved
one
based on those deceptive statistics so
this is very real
very serious and it has a real world
impact now what are the defenses
the defenses are what we heard from
health commissioner howard zucker from
new york
which is that the state website uh had
always been clear
that deaths it listed for nursing homes
did not include deaths that took place
outside the facility
and that the total number of deaths was
never under counted that's the defense
from the new york health health
department then there's the second piece
of this
which is the criticism that new york
state
sent nursing home residents who were
hospitalized
back to nursing homes in cases where
they shouldn't have been sent back
this one is more nebulous right now
we're still learning
learning more about it andrew cuomo is
defending this
and saying that everybody that was sent
back was sent back
in adherence to uh in compliance with
federal guidelines and that they didn't
do anything that was wrong now on the
second issue
i'm not really able to put together a
definitive take on it
we just need more information about that
now separately and this is a lot of
stuff happening all at once to andrew
cuomo separately there are allegations
of andrew cuomo being
basically a bad guy bullying employees
and treating employees terribly
i see this as important but secondary to
the covet scandal
it's a lot of he said she said i can't
possibly analyze it in any serious way
other than to say
all of the allegations should be
investigated and the cards
should fall where they may i don't care
that andrew cuomo's a democrat
whatever whatever is uncovered should be
what it is and
uh it should be dealt with and then
lastly there are also now
new allegations of inappropriate sexual
advances and conduct by andrew cuomo
lindsay boylan who worked for cuomo as
an aide
says that on a private jet cuomo
suggested playing strip poker which made
her feel uncomfortable
uh boylan says that that happened after
she was promoted to be
um cuomo's deputy secretary for economic
development and a special advisor to him
she said she initially turned the job
down because she didn't want to be near
him ultimately accepted it
boylan also is describing an incident
where uh they were
in his office in new york city on third
avenue and when she got up to leave
and walk out a door that andrew cuomo
allegedly stepped in front of her
kissed her on the lips and that she was
uh shocked but just kept walking out
now this is totally separate and uh
this allegation has to be taken
seriously and fully pursued
so that's the story as i understand it
some of the emails i received
were implying i wasn't going to talk
about this because cuomo is a democrat
first of all we talked about this last
week for a while on the bonus show
secondly i've said a million times i
don't care about these politicians
beyond their doing things for the people
i don't care if they're democrats or
republicans i never defended
you know anthony weiner i don't deify
politicians they all have good and bad
and why wouldn't i talk about andrew
cuomo investigate every single thing
if the people of new york want him to
resign he should consider resignation if
there are criminal wrongdoings
then investigate and prosecute we don't
ignore stories
because it's a democrat on this show
that is the full story as
i understand it so really sort of like
four stories the under count of nursing
home deaths
sending patients from hospitals back to
nursing homes
the bullying of employees and the
alleged sexual harassment
of lindsay boylan those are the four
stories as i understand them
they are separate stories we could sort
of group them as
the two covet stories and the two
bullying and harassment stories and
we'll just have to follow all of them
and see where the cards fall
if you were anything like me you
probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video